the german health authorities have today
reported a record 410 coronavirus
related deaths
it's a milestone which comes as the 16
state leaders are set to decide on
stricter lockdown measures
they have reportedly agreed to extend
coronavirus restrictions into december
with celebrations for holiday of
even able to take place now new daily
infections have leveled off but
germany's caseload
remains stubbornly high
the pressure is on for the german
government to ease restrictions for the
most important time of the year for many
christmas celebrations right now
berlin's john diamond mark square
would usually be packed with people
enjoying the christmas market
it's been cancelled people will be
allowed to gather at home for christmas
but in smaller groups still many accept
the reality that this year is different
there's going to be naturally some
opposition
it's natural it's going to happen but uh
it is what it is you know it's
there's no policy that's ever going to
be 100 uh
approved by the people i don't
understand why restriction would be
eased for christmas perhaps one should
stick to them
but i also see what happens with people
when they're lonely and happy
so i can't say much about it but i just
talk about it because i also see how it
is in hospitals that's where i work
yes it's sad not to celebrate christmas
as usual but how
else the measures taken are important
and necessary
and there's always skype so we'll see
the decision on christmas is expected to
be confirmed wednesday following talks
between state premiers and chancellor
angela merkel
the overall situation remains critical
we have high expectations as a
parliamentary group until now we have
begun to see a short trend of lower
figures in terms of infections which
means the exponential growth could be
stopped but that's not enough
we need lower figures especially for
christmas
christmas isn't the only celebration
that's on the line
many say that the much-loved tradition
of new year's eve fireworks needs to be
reined in
but a nationwide ban on fireworks sales
does not appear to be on the cards
ndw's emmanuel chazz is on the story she
joins us from berlin
how necessary is the extension of tough
measures
well sarah if you look at the cases on
tuesday germany recorded its highest
number of daily deaths
with more than 400 new deaths
and over 1800
000 new infections in a single day since
the beginning of the pandemic we count
almost a million cases overall and
almost 1500 000
deaths of course now the number of cases
plateau there's no longer an exponential
growth
but it's it is still far from being an
ideal situation here we definitely can't
say that the pandemic is under control
that being said if you compare the
situation in germany with that of
other countries well germany still fares
relatively well in comparison
hospitals are not overwhelmed for
example and if you look at the trends
for daily new coving 19 infections per
million inhabitants
we can see that there's still an
exponential growth in the us for example
where
germany's figures after a mild summer
seem to plateau
but still i mean we see very clearly on
that graph there the numbers are going
up and it is for that reason that
chancellor angela merkel has been
calling for even stricter measures
um but she's getting pushed some
pushback from the states
talk with us a little bit about that and
whether they might find some common
ground
yeah angela merkel has advocated for
tougher restrictions throughout but she
does have to find a common line with her
state premiers
she backed their proposal drafted on
monday
according to that draft if it's adopted
today we could see
additional measures in areas where
there's a high rate of infection for
example we could see tighter curbs on
gatherings
up until now up to 10 people from two
different households
could meet that could be reduced to five
people and nothing stands
a current measures will be extended with
shops remaining
open but restaurants bars fitness
studios remaining closed for now until
at least december the 20th
emanuela christmas we know a very
important holiday
you know religiously culturally for many
germans
what could a covet christmas look like
well i think stands um exceptions to
those restrictions
are on the cards for christmas members
of one household will be allowed to meet
with up to 10 other people from other
households
from december 23rd until the very
beginning of january some people are
relieved others are talked to
over the last few days including medical
personnel don't quite understand why
there would be such an exception
in any case people will be encouraged to
self-isolate before and after the
celebrations schools might also
break up a few days earlier as early as
uh mid-december
uh religious ceremonies will be alert
and also breaking is a long-standing
tradition on new year's eve and in a bit
to avoid public gatherings
there will be no public fireworks this
year emmanuel chaz
with the view from berlin thank you
let's have a look now at some other
developments in the coronavirus
pandemic france is relaxing its
coronavirus restrictions following a
drop in new infections
non-essential shops movie theaters and
museums will gradually reopen
but large gatherings will remain banned
australia's most populous state in new
south
wales has eased social distancing
measures and allowed companies to bring
employees back to work
after three weeks without a locally
transmitted case
and in the u.s a restaurant dining ban
comes into effect today in los angeles
the country's second biggest city the
three-week order comes as the state of
california
faces a record number of infections
well one european country finland has
managed to keep its
new coronavirus infection rates under
reasonable control
restaurants and bars are open for
business and stores
never closed there are few local
restrictions but there are fairly tight
rules aimed at keeping the virus
outside its borders
how has finland managed to keep the
coronavirus at bay
during this second wave it's not due to
harsh restrictions on citizens
because there aren't any masks are
recommended but not required in most
places
all stores are open
restaurants and bars are too although
orders for alcohol end at 11 p.m
passi pohula is director of the national
coronavirus strategy
he explains it relies on a sense of
personal responsibility
mere recommendations wouldn't work
everywhere but
here they do pins are quite obedient in
the sense that that when
they are suggested to kind of maintain
distance and
and avoid a lot of gatherings and a lot
of parties many people
intend to work with the way
it is suggested pohila says many finns
are working from home and that surveys
show
in-person social contacts have been cut
by two-thirds
so while the situation in finland is
very good at the moment compared with
the rest of europe
health authorities warned that this
requires constant vigilance
so while they are not making mask
wearing mandatory
they put up friendly reminders like this
one on city hall
that it's a very good idea if finns want
to maintain this way of life
but the number of new cases has started
to rise
so now the government has ordered
students over 12 to wear masks in school
and limited the size of social
gatherings in the helsinki area to 20
people
it also extended until at least
mid-december a
ban on all non-essential travel into the
country
finnish officials say in the summer half
of new coronavirus infections came from
abroad
that's dropped to 6 percent now that
tourists aren't allowed in
the european union is pressing
governments to restore open borders as
soon as possible
pohila says finland is grappling with
whether it can do that
and stay safe it is something that
looking a little bit
worried a little bit terrified also that
that we have
have to have a kind of a good model to
work with the
border issues to to maintain the
situation here in finland
one government proposal is that travel
restrictions could be eased
by making it mandatory to be tested on
arrival
timo arun kuta is deputy mayor of vanta
where the airport is located and he's
responsible for security there
he says his city doesn't have enough
medical professionals to carry this out
we have commun communicated to the
government
that if you lift restrictions and if you
make the law
that forces our staff
to move over to the airport the
situation is so that we cannot treat our
finnish people
anymore so well that we would like to
difficult decisions lie ahead for
finland as it tries to figure out how to
continue blocking the virus
but not visitors
you